many of you in this room know me and you
know I prided myself on my work ethic
but buddy I met my match Elon Musk has
chosen Linda yaccarino NBC Universal's
former head of advertising to become the
new CEO of Twitter musk confirms the
appointment on May 12th a day after
saying a new CEO would start in about
six weeks
Suzanne vernita covers the advertising
and marketing Industries for the journal
she explains yakarino's background and
what her selection says about the
direction Twitter could be headed
hi my friend Linda yaccarino is probably
the best known ad salesperson there is
on Madison Avenue she's got a flamboyant
and outgoing personality
she's got relationships that go from
Silicon Valley to New York she knows
marketers by first name she knows their
kids and she knows how to do her job one
media buying form calls Linda yac Arena
the velvet hammer and the reason for
that little nickname is because she is
one tough cookie when it comes to
getting money she can come off as the
friendliest person that you've ever
known but when they're in negotiations
look out she's tough this is a real
signal that Twitter needs this person to
reverse the advertising slide that
they've experienced you really need no
introduction
but in many ways today is your
introduction to the advertising
Community right I think that's a round
of applause hello
Missy ocarino has been warming up to
Elon for a couple months now and she
conducted an interview in Miami with him
recently and what was Apparent from that
is they both shared kind of the same
vision for what Twitter's going to be if
freedom of speech as he says is the
Bedrock of of this country I'm not sure
there's anyone in this room
who could disagree with that could I get
a round of applause for that she very
much believes that it should be a place
for free speech which is what Elon has
been talking about he's very adamant at
making sure that Twitter has different
voices and opinions that can be heard
following Elon musk's takeover of
Twitter advertisers exited big time from
Twitter they were really afraid that
Elon would lift all restrictions and
their ads would be appearing near unsafe
content that has basically kept a lot of
them at Bay and they have not returned
Linda yagarena knows full well that this
is an issue because she used to use this
to her Advantage when she was at nbcu
she would attack the digital channels
for having content that was too
controversial and hoping to make sure
that Brands would stick with big
broadcast network for safeties so I
suspect that she'll make sure that
Twitter invests in new tools to keep
Brands away from unsafe content the
biggest challenge I think that Lindy
Ocarina will face when she heads to
Twitter is Twitter is run by a bunch of
the engineers and coders and that's an
experience that she doesn't have much on
the good news is that Elon has already
signaled that he will handle the
majority of that part of business but
it'll interesting enough to see how
these two actually learned to work
together
foreign